Transcriber: SHIMA BAGHERZADEH
المدقّق: Yasmeen Elsayed
صباح الخير أنا اسمي ياسين وائل علاء الدين،
وعمري 7 سنوات، أدرس الروبوتات،
وأنا في الصف الثاني في مدرسة المنارات.
أتيت اليوم لأعرفكم على شيء.
هل شاهد أحدكم الروبوتات من قبل؟
أو يعرف معلومات عنها أو يدرسها؟
يمكن أن تستخدم الروبوتات في مجالات كثيرة.
في مجالات كثيرة مثل الهندسة والطب والطبخ.
وسأُحَدثكم عن الطبخ اليوم،
حيث يمكنها أن تقوم بعمل الكثير في الطبخ،
مثل أن تُعِد طعامًا صحيًا لا يُتعب الأمهات
ويكون مفيدًا وتنهيه بسرعة دون تعب،
ومثل ذلك في المطاعم.
أنا سأحدثكم أيضًا عن الطب،
حيث يُمكن أن تستخدم في الطب، مثلا كأن يقوم
أبي بإجراء عملية من مصر
لشخص في أوروبا عن طريق الروبوتات.
أنا جئت لأحكي لكم حكاية صغيرة جدًا جدًا،
وهي أن أمي الشهيدة
الدكتورة رغدة أحمد الدخاخني
توفت بفيروس الكورونا.
وكنت أتمنى لو كنت أكبر قليلاً
لأصنع روبوتًا
يمنع نقل العدوى لها من المرضى.
كان لدي شغف كبير جدًا في صنع الروبوتات.
وأحب أن أشكر عائلتي وأبي وأمي وجدي وجدتي،
وأشكر تيد إكس وأشكركم أيضًا على متابعتكم،
وأشكر الدكتور وائل وأشكركم.
وأتمنى أن تدرسوا الروبوتات
وتجعلوا أطفالكم يدرسون الربوتات.
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته.